Hello Freak bitches.
What were some of,
when you were treating patients in the
clinical pathology thing?
Like what were some of the patterns that
you saw that were,
you know,
really for some of the real challenges
that people face?
Like growing up,
you know,
like what were the main themes that were
the hardest,
hardest to deal with and bring into a
healthy adult life?
Trauma and disconnection.
Disconnection from like what Joe was
saying in regards to mentorship and
having,
having a big brother or somebody in that
role that they could aspire to be like,
that could coach them through
challenging situations and going through
trauma because trauma is so rampant and
it's also our,
our representation in our
internalization of trauma.
Some people take that on as an identity,
that they've been traumatized or they've
been abused and,
and because it's not discussed,
it's in fact shamed.
Um,
it's not really dealt with above board,
whether it's people being traumatized
sexually because the,
the perpetrator,
the person actually doing the traumatic
event,
they weren't integrated in their own
sexuality.
So it came out in a perverse way,
or it was the internalization of
something that seemed mild,
but because they didn't have the
languaging and the opportunity to
connect with somebody that it,
it held and seated over time.
Like if you see animals in the wild,
when they get traumatized,
like if you were driving a car and you
hit a deer,
the first thing that deer is going to do
when he gets to the side of the road,
it's going to shake it out.
It's going to just move that somatically
out of its body because trauma gets
imprinted into the sematic
infrastructure like,
but on,
he was talking about until the,
like the Fascia trauma gets fat,
kids gets programmed into the body,
it also gets trauma.
We'll change the genetic expression.
You actually see the DNA genetic code
change its expression at the time of
trauma.
And that can be recapitulated
transgenerationally.
So from generation to generation to
generation,
I can still hold my parents' trauma,
my granddaughters,
an epigenetic phenomenon.
It's a transgenerational epigenetic
phenomena.
Right?
So that's so crazy.
It's so crazy.
So we we are,
and that's what the native Americans
talk about.
Like our,
our actions right now do affect seven
generations down the line because it
takes that long to bleed it out of the
jeans unless you clear it.
Yeah.
That's one thing that's weird about
opening for bands.
They will tune up while you're onstage.
Well,
on that level yet,
I mean,
when I work with Sherra was classy
because she was the one that,
that was the,
by far the best job I ever had an
opening for anybody because she knows
she had a great crowd.
She had transvestites and mothers with
the grandmothers,
with their grandchildren,
which is the audience.
Yeah.
You know what the security told me if
they ever saw a single straight guy
alone this thing,
any,
he looks straight,
they would,
they would track him all night because
no,
no guy along goes to a Cher concert of
his straight,
a gay guy dancing and happy.
No problem.
So if someone's going to be like a crazy
stalker,
it's going to be straight,
straight guy.
But she was fun though before.
Yeah.
You enjoyed working with her,
right?
Yeah,
I really liked her.
Do you ever feel like a friendship with
her?
Do you contact her?
I'm not anymore,
but you know,
she's,
she's very isolated,
you know,
she's a good person.
And she was like,
she used to ask me about the world,
like she wasn't really in it because she
wasn't really in it to go,
well what's it like?
And you know,
she asked me about people and one night
we went to,
I said,
I talked her into going out in Montreal.
look,
why don't you drop the outfits,
stop wearing a top hat and a cane.
And like maybe nobody will notice.
You know,
I could just fix her with the fucking
tales does lastly the dead,
the dead,
skipping back and forth.
And she is,
you know,
so we got to an ice cream place and some
like old,
I'd go in and look with French gut,
hey,
aren't you the famous one?
What's her name?
And that's all she had to hear it.
She goes,
yeah,
who could ever forget all,
what's her name?
So then now the validated that she can't
go out,
you know.
But one guy.
That's it.
Yeah.
But we had a good time.
You know,
we stayed with was a funny thing in the
casino we would meet,
uh,
when I like in the,
in the arenas I would do my act,
then they'd have a break and then she'd
come up.
So we'd never see each other except when
she had it,
like a team prayer.
And then sometimes I was in that.
But um,
when,
uh,
when she's,
we would cross each other one night her
grandmother and grandfather were there
and she said to me,
she goes,
you just did it.
Just joke with my grandparents there.
And I said,
by the way,
your answers out and your grandfather's
looking at it.
And she stopped the lift.
I got flagged for a while where I was
pulled every time I went to Vancouver
airport because one time I was leaving
is weird.
My wife had got me new bag.
It came with like,
she bought me some Cologne and then it
came,
it was a Calvin Klein bag late,
just a duffel bag that came with the
Cologne.
So I packed my stuff.
It was like a two day trip to New York.
It was when I was first doing the union,
I was looking for Cruz and I was
interviewing producers and stuff like
that and it was just a quick trip.
But then I came back and then they
pulled me aside and then they tested my
bag and they're like,
your bag is tested positive for cocaine.
And I was like,
what?
I was like,
bullshit.
show it to me.
I was like,
I didn't know.
Understand at the time when they're
like,
we found cocaine all over your bag.
I'm like,
bullshit,
let me see it.
There's no cocaine in my bag.
And they said,
no,
no.
Like we tested it.
There's particles.
Why would it be on there?
Do you do cocaine?
I'm like,
never in my life.
Not even tried it,
you know like,
well how is it all over your bag?
I'm like,
I have no idea.
And then so we went in the back for
hours and they're like,
they're like,
Hey,
quit playing this game.
We talked to your friend.
I'm like,
good.
Well,
he would have told you the same thing.
So I was traveling with a friend and I
was like,
he would have told you the same thing,
good cop,
bad cop.
I'm like,
yeah.
He's like,
he told the drill and I was like,
wow.
Yeah,
that.
We went to New York,
we're looking at developing a
documentary and then it finally came
down to where I said,
okay,
like tell me how this particle thing
works.
Because I did the night deposit for my
nightclub the night before.
Right.
And they say a large majority of money,
especially in nightclubs and stuff.
I asked cocaine on it,
right.
People do a rail wipe their hand grabbed
the bill,
and I'd done the cash deposit for the
nightclub right before our flight.
I'd put it in that bag,
went to the night deposit,
put it in the bank,
and then I flew out to like six or seven
in the morning and like pack my gear
instead of,
so I said,
could it be that like cocaine was on the
money that was in,
in my bag that,
and they're like,
yes,
we can trace particles like that.
I'm like,
well then there's your answer.
But then they looked at my club strip
club Cheetahs this night and then there,
then it was just like we were in there
longer and I was like,
ah.
So every time I came back and here's the
interesting thing is every time I came
back to Vancouver they flagged,
they'd pull me aside,
pulled me and finally I was so mad.
I was like one in the morning.
I was like,
please just don't pull me aside.
I'm so tired.
I got to drive to the outskirts of
Vancouver to stay at my buddy's place.
I just want to go to bed,
please go to the side.
I'm like,
so I was so mad.
I just laid on their metal counter.
I was tired neck cause you know they do
the thing where they put you over there
and then nobody comes for like half
hour,
just make you sit there.
So I just laid,
I started napping.
It was exhausted like one 30 in the
morning,
coming back from New York.
I laid up there and the girl comes to
get down.
I'm like,
I'm tired.
It's one 30 in the morning,
I'm really tired and I'm not playing any
games like she and I finally just said,
why am I getting pulled over all the
time?
I've never broken a law.
You can't like,
there's nothing every check your thing.
I've never done anything.
I've never brought over items that I
shouldn't,
I haven't meet.
And she's like,
well,
the big problem is is that one time your
bag got test.
And I was like,
I explained that and that should all be
in the notes,
right?
She said,
yeah,
but we always don't trust it when you
say you don't do the product right and
it's all over your bag because then we
think you're a smuggler.
She's like,
you're almost better to just say,
Yup,
I did some cocaine with friends or
whatever and we don't have any on me.
And I was like,
but I don't.
I don't do it.
I'm not going to say I did it.
And she's like,
well,
that's why they think you're maybe a
smuggler.
You're doing quick trips to New York.
It's on your bag.
Well,
it's like the guy who got in trouble for
structuring
you did it similar to what it is we're
going to take.
Your money was just cash.
They have a bunch of different
techniques that they teach these
knuckleheads to try to like recognize
shady people.
And so they like think they're fucking
spies.
They're like think they're detectives
staring at everybody.
But that Jamie Bern and look at his
face,
I saw a deceptive tips.
Her and I immediately pulled out of the
line.
I actually got the guy really pissed off
when it,
cause I used to get,
these were the Canadian guys and I'm a
Canadian stuff,
so I was like,
you can't kick me out of my own country.
So I battle with them a little bit
harder.
Right.
And the one guy asked me,
he's like,
have you ever done a narcotic?
And I was like,
no,
never done it.
Narcotic.
It's like,
if you never smoked weed,
I'm like,
that's not a narcotic.
Narcotic comes from the Latin word,
meaning narcosis causing asleep and do
state,
which is usually applied to opiates and
heroin and stuff like that.
I was like,
no.
marijuana is a psycho tropical drawing.
I think he was just like,
you psycho tropic,
right?
That's a tropical.
It's like a,
it's part of the world.
And,
and uh,
and he was just like,
let's not get to the nitty gritty.
And I said,
no,
no.
You're a border guard.
You're asking me questions.
I'm answering honestly.
So if you're going to ask me questions,
you make sure you answered that.
You asked me the right one and I will
give you the correct answer.
And he was like,
go,
you can go.
That's the difference.
You,
Canadians and Americans,
Americans,
Canadians,
more willing to admit the feet.
Excuse me.
Sorry.
Okay.